Hello Freak bitches do.
Ooh,
I'm here with confirmed cosmonaut Steve.
Oh yeah,
man.
Who's been to space a man who knows about the atmosphere.
I can't say I've been to space.
I went up in a Russian Mig fighter jet to the edge of the earth's atmosphere.
Hi.
Was that,
do you know?
I fucking forget shit.
I fucking forget.
But it wasn't that much higher than,
so normal flight is like 100,000 thousand.
And then what's like,
I've heard the Galt,
they've go higher.
Right?
They can go up to like 35,000 for commercial flight.
I want to say that the,
that I,
that it might've been like,
not much more than 50,000,
but I,
I,
I can't back that up.
I don't remember.
Maybe it was,
it was shockingly less than you would imagine.
Oh,
that's you.
I had a video of it because it showed us wild boys.
Oh,
no shit.
Oh look,
it's going straight up.
Oh my God.
He's a lot of,
uh,
they used a lot of,
um,
stock footage,
but at the same time,
on the way down,
this mother fucker did twirls and fuck it was,
it wasn't like the gnarliest rollercoaster ride ever.
Ah.
And like,
and this is me filming myself like Louie that too.
Oh my God.
It's fucking night up there.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That shows for anybody wants to say that the fucking world is flat.
That's what I can prove.
Motherfuckers.
Well,
you can see the curvature of the earth.
Wow.
That's nuts.
And so when you were doing this,
um,
did,
did you get goals close to blacking out?
Like how has the gene,
of course,
um,
I didn't get close to black man or anything like that and uh,
I thought that that it would be one thing.
What it was was I was just fucking claustrophobic.
Man is in cramped in a tiny little,
I get claustrophobic.
Yeah,
I didn't like that.
Did you,
uh,
do you,
did they tell you how many g forces you were doing had?
That's another thing.
I can't remember,
but,
uh,
I feel like there was more g shit going on when we did the,
the zero gravity plane.
Oh,
okay.
Which,
um,
you know,
it just kind of goes along and then it does a big bell curve kind of deal.
So you'd become weightless.
Right.
And that one,
you could feel yourself really like being pulled down with the gs or whatever.
Yeah.